sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
mit dabei sind steht vor der tür und
auch der sommer ist nicht mehr so
richtig weit weg aus
urlaub auf abstand wie das aussehen
könnte hat das himmelfahrtswochenende
gezeigt die menschen wollen raus
durch die lockerung der beschränkungen
haben wir natürlich einen ansturm hier
ein tagesausflüge dem wir so noch nicht
gekannt haben wo er am sonntag um ein
regelrechtes verkehrschaos gehabt wenn
der anfang ist was passiert uns dann
eigentlich im sommer auch an der ostsee
bilder wie aus besseren zeiten
zehntausende touristen volle strände
volle cafés volle parkplätze abstand
halten wird da zur auslegungssache
ein vorgeschmack auf pfingsten und auf
den corona sommer rund 80 prozent der
deutschen planen einen urlaub zu hause
in deutschland wie locker dürfen wir uns
machen
thüringens linker ministerpräsident
ramelow will weniger verbote und warnt
vor einem polizeistaat
wir wollen langfristig nicht immer
weiter mit notverordnungen arbeiten wir
greifen in die grundrechte der bürger
ein
16 bundesländer 16 lockerungs pläne und
dazwischen eine kanzlerin die zur
disziplin mahnt doch ihr corona comeback
scheint wenige wochen vor den
sommerferien vorbei
es liegt in der verantwortung der einst
ministerpräsidenten und land und
stadtkreise dies jetzt
verantwortungsvoll zu handhaben und aus
sind sie eigentlich dankbar für die
rückendeckung aus thüringen bodo ramelow
wird schon der ost laschet genannt also
das habe ich noch nicht gehört
sind das auch keine angemessene
beschreibung das sind ja zwei
unterschiedliche dinge über die wir
gesprochen haben ich habe in all den
wochen in den letzten wochen immer darum
geworben abzuwägen
auch die schäden des lockdown zu sehen
die verschiebung von operationen das
nicht stattfindet von reha-maßnahmen die
frage die kinder betrifft die über
wochen und monate nicht in der kita und
in der schule waren
und ich habe immer gesagt dann wenn wir
die chance sehen wieder zurückzukommen
ins öffentliche und soziale leben dann
sollten wir die ergreifen und wir haben
das sozusagen wir haben es am 20 april
gemacht
zum ersten mal am 6 mai mit den
gaststätten zum zweiten mal
und wenn ich mir heute von der helmholtz
initiative den l wehrt anschaue dann
liegt er bei 0,63 in ganz deutschland
bei 0,5 in nordrhein westfalen
das heißt die menschen haben sich auch
nach den öffneten öffnungen an die
regeln gehalten und das war immer mein
ziel den menschen da auch etwas zutrauen
und jetzt sagen sie wie bodo ramelow weg
von den verboten und hin zu den geboten
nein das sage ich nicht ich sage wir
brauchen weiter die regeln
beispielsweise vorschrift abstand halten
da wo der abstand nicht zu halten ist
masken pflicht also wir brauchen weiter
die regeln
ich teile auch nicht die auffassung von
winfried kretschmann dass wir nicht mit
der bundeskanzlerin weitersprechen
sollten wir brauchen möglichst
deutschlandweiter rahmenbedingungen aber
ich verstehe wenn in vielen ostdeutschen
ländern die infektionen quasi bei null
sind dass man da auch noch einmal ganz
anders diskutiert anders diskutiert
katja kipping ist bei uns eine der
beiden vorsitzenden von der linken
sie warnen frau kipping immer noch vor
zu vielen lockerungen da ist der
gegensatz zu ihrem parteifreund in
thüringen bodo ramelow eigentlich nicht
größer warum denken sie spielt der
ministerpräsident mit dem feuer
also auch wenn ich nicht jeden satz
teile den bodo ramelow gesagt hat muss
ich jetzt doch sozusagen eines auch in
schutz nimmt das ja nicht als ost
laschet bezeichnet werden kann
ich würde sagen es gibt schon ein
unterschied armin laschet ist als erstes
eingestiegen und hat druck gemacht dass
die autohäuser geöffnet werden bodo
ramelow erste sozusagen
zielgruppe war die öffnung der schulen
da kann man auch mal unterschiedlicher
meinung sein aber ob ich mich
zuallererst für autohäuser im engagiere
wie das herr laschet gemachte sozialer
erst für die schulen
das ist schon ein unterschied ums ganze
so dass man jetzt zur ehrenrettung von
bodo ramelow sollten sie das unbedingt
loswerden
markus söder bayerischer präsident
kritisierte laschet ist gleich daran
kritisiert auf das heftigste was sich
thüringens spd hat einfallen lassen
er sagt das ist gefährlich das ist fatal
bayern würde sich überlegen wenn das so
käme auch gegenmaßnahmen zu starten
warum glauben sie macht er das naja wir
geben uns alle mühe hier immer streng
nach sozusagen rationellen abwägen zu
reagieren aber als parteipolitik dass
man ja nie ganz frei von parteipolitik
das spiel bestimmt auch mit rein und ein
weiterer punkt also ich finde schon das
kind ist in den brunnen gefallen als
zwischen ministerpräsidenten und
bundesregierung die bundesweite
einheitlichkeit aufgekündigt wurde und
ich weiß weil ich nach den schalten mit
bodo ramelow telefoniert habe dass er
immer sehr darauf gedrängt hat dass es
weiterhin ein bundesweiter
einheitlichkeit gibt dass die aufgerufen
wurde gingen ja eher von anderen aus
aber jetzt haben wir die situation und
dann ist es natürlich so dass
bundesländer wo es landkreise gibt wo
die zehn landkreise wo du 0
neuinfektionen hast das doch noch mal
ganz anderer druck ist inwieweit man
regional wirklich das virus dann noch
stoppen und bekämpfen kann das kann
vielleicht zuerst wissenschaftler
verbessert seine liebe arbeiten aber
dass wir schon dass es noch eine andere
situation ob du im land bist wo mehrere
landkreise wirklich null neuinfektionen
haben und das heißt sie plädieren wenn
sie jetzt aber bei ihrer haltung bleiben
ihre sehr kritischen gegen diese
lockerungen
sie plädieren dann eben nicht für mehr
eigenverantwortung sondern sie sagen es
muss weiter die bußgelder geben wenn man
zu viel im restaurant sitzt oder wenn
man gemeinsam im gottesdienst sinkt und
sitzt
na ja der einsatz um den es hier geht es
ja ein hoher es geht um menschenleben
und da ist es schwierig wenn man
irgendwie sagt wuchs im ich habe mich
geirrt wir waren zu schnell deswegen ist
all die fortschritte die wir jetzt
gemacht haben und wenn man hört dass
womöglich jetzt auch wissenschaftler
sagen dass wir um eine zweite welle drum
herum kommen wissen wir noch nicht ob
das wirklich so eintrifft aber dann ist
es ja noch volk den wir auch der
vorsicht der million menschen verdanken
und glaube dass es wichtig ist dass von
politischer seite da auch sehr klare
ansagen weiterhin kommen dass nicht der
eindruck entsteht jetzt kann man alle
vorsicht fallen lassen dann ist die
gefahr dass wir eine zweite welle kommen
verheerend und die hat nicht nur viele
tote und gesundheitliche schäden zur
folge sondern die wir heute auch für die
vielen unternehmen verheerend weil dann
würde man jetzt zurück in den modus des
shuttles gehen und das will man
niemanden in der gastronomie zumuten und
was das für die reisebüros bedeutet mag
ich mir gar nicht außerdem wir haben die
gesamte industrie bedeuten würde das ist
auch alles schon modelliert wurden bei
uns ist jonas schmidt-chanasit virologe
tropenmediziner bernhard nocht institut
in hamburg
herr schmidt chanasit markus söder
bleiben wir noch mal ganz kurz bei ihm
hat sorge vor den thüringer nachbarn und
will aber auf der anderen seite den
tourismus in deutschland fördern
passt das zusammen für sie ich glaube
dann so einfach ist es nicht ich habe
das auch in thüringen so verstanden dass
man natürlich steckt von den pauschalen
maßnahmen zu spezifischen intelligenten
maßnahmen kommen will um zielgerichtet
schnell reagieren zu können und das
finde ich sehr gut das kann man
unterstützen
man kann sich mehr freiheit durch
clevere smarte maßnahmen letztendlich
erkaufen das wird mehr geld kosten weil
wir einfach auch natürlich mehr testen
müssen wir müssen in der lage sein wenn
diese events auftreten wie einen lehrer
oder auch in frankfurt schnell reagieren
zu können um eine weiterverbreitung eben
möglich schnell einzudämmen
und dann kann man auch letztendlich mehr
zu lassen und wenn
dann jetzt weil wenn wir erstmal in
einer zweiten welle sind dann haben wir
die möglichkeit nicht mehr als wir
müssen jetzt auch diese chance nutzen
gerade bei den kitas und bei den schulen
um auch zu sehen welche faktoren eine
rolle spielen ob es zu einer
weiterverbreitung kommt in den schulen
oder ob das nicht der fall das insofern
ist jetzt eine gelegenheit dazu
wenn und immer noch wissen wie sehr
wenig was wir wissen ist dass uns in
bozen reinhold messner zugeschaltet ist
der mann der die meisten achttausender
bestiegen hat und der nicht nur an der
unter bergsteiger ist sondern auch autor
und unternehmer vermessen einen schönen
guten abend sie kommen aus südtirol das
muss man eigentlich nie sagen auch in
den dolomiten kennen sie jeden berg und
die südtiroler leben vom tourismus
das beste gesundes richtig in das beste
gesundheitliche wäre wenn die menschen
zu hause blieben sagte zuletzt auch der
chef des welt ärzte bundes montgomery
das wäre nun aber das glatte gegenteil
von tourismus also ich finde dass gerade
die gebirge der erbe viele möglichkeiten
geben auch zur gesundung
das stärkt das immunsystem im übrigen
die berge geben die möglichkeit dass
sich die menschen verlieren
60 prozent ihrer fläche sind wälder und
almen wo keine infrastrukturen sind
keine ballungszentren sind das in den
letzten jahrzehnten infrastrukturen
geschaffen worden sind
diese events produziert wurden im
gebirge das war ein großer fehler und
ich hoffe dass diese pandemie am ende
hilft denn wir heraus und sein sollten
dass wir umdenken und den tourismus oder
die sonne nicht mehr so vorbereiten dass
man große massen auf irgendeinem gipfel
auf eine plattform hinauf bringt sondern
dass man die leute wirklich sich
sanieren lässt in diese stille in diese
erhabenheit in diese ja auch relativ
gesunde luft braucht aber dann nicht
südtirol dennoch auch insgesamt mehr
tourismus jetzt herr messner
nein wir werden nie die zahlen erreichen
der letzten jahre
mein der winter war ja
voll ausgelastet man hat ja im märz
april mai die hotel ist die seilbahnen
gesperrt richtigerweise südtirol hat
sehr früh angefangen einen starken
strich zu machen
und jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich dass
julia august dauern bis die menschen
wieder dritten wenn wir südtiroler nicht
sozusagen den schengen raum im
hintergrund haben den gesamten
schengen-raum dann können wir nicht
überleben wir leben in erster linie vom
tourismus diese berglandwirtschaft ist
kleinräumig die gehört zwar dazu ist
verzahnt mit dem tourismus aber die
erfolge wirtschaftlich hat südtirol so
den tourismus auch weil wir
international arbeiten können
die interessen italienisch englisch und
deutsch wir hoffen auch auf italienische
gäste in diesem sommer da werden wir
noch zu kommen das war schon eine kleine
werbung für südtirol oder eine große wie
man will
herr laschet noch mal auf die politik
geschaut der bundesaußenminister heiko
maas will jetzt die ausgangs und aus
reisebeschränkungen die reisewarnungen
die es gegeben hat aufheben
damit ist er bisher auf widerspruch
gestoßen vor allen dingen von der csu
werden sie den bundesaußenminister
unterstützen bei dem unterfangen diese
lockerungen jetzt auch europaweit
möglich zu machen ab dem 15 06
trotz der wieder worte aus münchen also
ich finde dass wir vieles nicht so
parteipolitisch betrachten soll
das war kipping zum beispiel eben
geschildert hat mit den autohäusern
stimmt ja nicht wir haben mit schulen
und kitas begonnen wir sind jetzt das
erste land das in den vollbetrieb der
kitas geht deshalb sollte uns das
einfach sparen
das zweite auch diese frage der
reisewarnung sollten wir von der sache
her entscheiden
ich war immer gegen grenzschließung wir
haben alles erreicht man an der belgisch
niederländischen grenze was er nie
geschlossen während der ganzen krise
während alle anderen dachten
grenzschließungen sind was gutes ist es
bei uns gelungen über die grenze hinweg
zu kooperieren und deshalb müssen wir
mitte juni spätestens
eine europäische lösung finden wie
wieder der schengen raum hergestellt
wird und der bundesaußenminister hat vor
angesichts der infektions lage in den
europäischen ländern einen konsens
herbeizuführen dass wir wieder uns in
europa bewegen können und wenn das sein
ziel ist dann hat er meine volle
unterstützung sind sie dabei herr
schmidt schaller sind die whu findet
interessanterweise geschlossene grenzen
ohnehin nicht hilfreich bei der
bekämpfung einer solche helfen grenzen
also nicht gegen das wir uns ja ja es
ist seit langem und die meinung der wm
auch eine erfahrung aus anderen
ausbrüchen gerade in afrika wo
grenzschließung erheblich dazu
beigetragen haben die versorgungslage
vor ort zu erschweren und das war ja
hier auch die wir am anfang der pandemie
gesehen haben zum teil problematisch
haben die langen schlangen an den
grenzen gesehen also sowas muss
vermieden werden man hat dann keine gute
lösung gefunden dass der warenverkehr
eigentlich problemlos stattfinden kann
und wenn entsprechende test systeme
etabliert sind und entsprechende
sicherheiten auch in deutschland jetzt
vorhanden sind um infektionen schnell
aufzudecken einzudämmen
dann denke ich steht ihm auch nichts
entgegen und es gibt ja gute beispiele
auch in österreich das zb reisende auch
getestet werden können kostenlos und
ähnliches szenario kann man sich nämlich
auch in deutschland vorstellen
dagegen wäre ein echter europäer ist
kann der eigentlich für geschlossene
grenzen plädieren und damit den
südländern auch einnahmen aus diesem
tourismus vorenthalten ich glaube die
große gefahr bei der infektion geht ja
nicht von der grenze aus weil das virus
ist ja schon immer auf beiden seiten der
grenze in europa und weltweit sondern
die infektionsgefahr steigt generell mit
verkehr und mobilität und wenn viele
menschen vor allem in geschlossenen
räumen zusammen sind oder wenn es
generell massen events gibt so das heißt
also wenn wir die infektionszahlen
dämmen wollen müssen wir die treffpunkte
an massenevents viele menschen in
geschlossenen räumen und generell
mobilität und verkehr und das muss halt
sozusagen alles in allen reduzieren ob
man dann eine landesgrenze über kreis
eine kreisgrenze oder eine bundesgrenze
das ist nicht der punkt deswegen sind
die zu begrenzen
das entscheiden wir die frage ist was
hört man alles rennt und männer in denen
generell die sachen runterfallen
natürlich die sicherheitsregeln
einhalten getestet getestet und wir
müssen alles tun dass wenn es einen
impfstoff gibt der wirklich global
weltweit auch zum einsatz kommt
das ist meine große sorge wenn der
entsteht das dann gewisse seinen labore
einfachen patentrecht darauf haben dass
ich nun reichen ländern der zum einsatz
kommt und dann in einer globalen welt
erhalten manchen kontinenten ihm
bekämpft werden kann und damit auch
immer wieder zu bekommen und damit
zurückkommen kann europa
vergemeinschaftet noch nicht die
schulden aber wenn jetzt ein
reiseverkehr wieder losgehen würde dann
bald das ansteckungsrisiko
also wenn man will dass sie mich nach
risiken fragen habe ich keine sorge
gehabt bei den öffnungen der letzten
wochen
ich habe aber etwas sorge wie das wird
wenn die menschen in ganz europa
unterwegs sind auf nicht bekannte
menschen aus anderen ländern treffen wo
man die infektionsketten schwer
nachvollziehen kann und deshalb brauchen
wir eigentlich standards in europa die
man möglichst europäisch auch vereinbart
die unseren deutschen standards ähnlich
sind also eine ballermann party ein
sangria trinken aus dem eimer mit
strohhalmen kann ich mir beim besten
willen nicht vorstellen
und deshalb müssen wir zum beispiel in
diesem einen beispiel es gibt auch
andere ich spiel war das in österreich
und der karneval im rheinland und vieles
andere
solche ereignisse muss man unterbinden
und man braucht in allen hotels und
ferienanlagen möglichst konzepte die
abstand die hygieneregeln und alles das
was wir uns in deutschland vorgenommen
haben mit den partnern zusammen auch
dort umsetzen
über diese möglichen maßnahmen wenn wir
noch reden frage nach bozen zu reinhold
messner in italien ist nun ausgerechnet
der ärger über deutschland in der krise
sehr gewachsen weil man einfach das
gefühl hatte dass die deutschen zu wenig
getan haben für auch die italienischen
nachbarn ist in europa sind europas
bürger einander entfremdet durch die
kuchener krise also es gibt keinen
zweifel
bei der krone krisenbeginn hat europa
nicht gemeinsam gearbeitet entschieden
strategien entwickelt damit ist es
natürlich wieder ein bisschen
auseinander gebrochen was ja schon seit
mehreren jahren wenn nicht jahrzehnten
passiert wieder beobachten ich bin
europäer begeisterter europäer und sehe
das mit einem weinenden auge
jetzt allerdings in letzter zeit makro
merkel haben ja einen vorschlag gemacht
wären italien gut ankam
vorher haben die einzelnen bürger in
italien über die deutschen geschützt
wenn nun einzelne deutsche gäste also
feriengäste aus deutschland nach italien
kämen dann wäre das eine art zeichen ja
dass solidarität die können wie früher
die großen kunstdenkmäler anschauten
venedig florenz roma natürlich auch in
die berge kommen ich will jetzt nicht
nur für südtirol sprechen aber es wäre
ganz gut wenn viele deutsche urlauber
italien aufsuchen würden vielleicht dort
wo keine ballungsräume mit gästen
entstehen
das wichtigste ist jetzt dass wir die
regeln einhalten die wir gemeinsam dann
vielleicht untermauern wir herr laschet
sagt und bin ich der gleichen meinung
europäische europaweit aber die leute
sollten untereinander wieder zirkulieren
um ein europa gefühl und da eine art
solidarität zu spüren um die solidarität
auch zu zeigen sie befürchten
nicht dass es so einen zustand gibt wie
man braucht die deutschen aber man kann
sie weniger leiden denn je nein die
deutschen sind das beliebteste volk
weltweit in der letzten zeit wenn da und
dort einmal kritik aufkommt ist das war
ich habe in den 50er und 60er jahren vor
allem ende 60 70 dann mit meinen vielen
reisen weltweit gemerkt wieder respekt
vor den deutschen war
wer ist schon sehr tief unten ich sage
nicht nur auf ein relativ hohes level
gestiegen und es halt nicht nur ich das
einen viele internationale beobachter
das respekt vor den deutschen wieder
gestiegen ist nicht nur weil sie ihre
schlimme zeit besser aufgearbeitet haben
als andere sondern weil auch sehr viel
solidarität aus dem von deutschland
allerdings in bestimmten punkten wurde
dann natürlich auch deutschland wird
mindestens gedacht wenn auch nicht
ausgerichtet am anfang in österreich ist
was noch eindeutiger kommt ja auch noch
zu herr schmidt chanasit
im grunde ist jetzt tatsächlich durch
den tourismus irgendwann vielleicht
dieses virus einigermassen gerecht
verteilt in deutschland und in europa
was denken sie denn dass man beobachten
und beachten sollte wenn man sich eine
reise bucht wie das nächste krankenhaus
ausgestattet ist oder wo es liebt das
ist eine ganz wichtige frage und dafür
gibt es eben reisemedizinische beratung
die man durchaus jedem reisen empfehlen
kann der in europa verreist und da wird
nicht nur corona besprochen sondern auch
alle andere aspekte die neben corona
eine rolle spielen
die impfungen werden kontrolliert die
zum beispiel auch schon in schweden oder
auch in den baltischen ländern eine
wichtige rolle spielen könnten
und genau das sollte man eben befolgen
dort wird auch nochmal auf die aktuelle
situation eingegangen eine
risikobewertung gemacht und dann muss
letztendlich jeder für sich entscheiden
ob er dieses risiko bereit ist
einzugehen
und das ist letztendlich das wir auch
als ärzte die reisemedizinische beratung
machen leisten müssen und wollen genauso
tun spätestens im juli wollen viele
europäische länder wieder für touristen
öffnen gucken wir uns mal die aktuellen
fallzahlen der beliebtesten sind sie zu
sehen ja sehr gut der beliebtesten
europäischen ferienländern deutschland
österreich italien dann frankreich mit
28.000 toten erreicht nicht ganz italien
portugal wenig niederlande und
griechenland wenn das so genannte
infektionsgeschehen entscheidet herr
schmidt chanasit dann hätten
stand heute griechenland und portugal
also einen vorteil gegenüber italien an
spanien stand heute aber das ist eben
gerade das interessante dass ich dieses
infektionsgeschehen auch regional
deutlich unterscheidet selbst innerhalb
italiens und das ist zum teil eben nicht
verstanden was wir ihm zunehmend
verstehen und es wurde auch schon
angesprochen dass die sogenannten super
special events also wenige menschen oder
ein mensch viele anstieg eine
entscheidende rolle spielen und ist
genau gilt dieses zu verhindern und die
maßnahmen die schon erwähnt wurden
sondern das schild oder frau kipping
sind genau die richtigen
auch das vermessen erwähnt hat natürlich
ist die gefahr in den werden relativ
bringen nur ich muss erstmal natürlich
dahin kommen
das ist die entscheidende frage wo wir
uns auch gedanken machen müssen
natürlich wenn ich allein ins auto
steigen von berlin eben nach südtirol
fahrer wird die wahrscheinlichkeit mich
zu infizieren und geringer sein als wenn
ich im hinspiel armin laschet viele
länder wollen derzeit auch schweden
nicht ins land lassen
das sieht irgendwie alles mehr nach
einem zwei klassen euro voraus als
wirklich nach einer großen einigkeit
befürchten sie nicht dass wir in europa
einen ähnlichen flickenteppich ernten
wie in deutschland
ich glaube in deutschland ist der
flickenteppich gar nicht so groß wie
immer gesagt wird fast alle machen die
ähnlichen maßnahmen in unterschiedlichen
abständen aber entscheidend ist dass wir
eine europäische antwort finden
das hat reinhold messner ja eben
beschrieben wir saßen wir zusammen im
europäischen parlament haben dafür
geworben dass man nicht
nationalstaatlich glaubt solche großen
probleme lösen zu können
und die infizierten zahlen die sie
gerade gezeigt haben waren ja
gesamtzahlen der letzten monate man muss
eigentlich exakt schauen wie ist das
infektionsgeschehen im moment und wie
sind die maßnahmen die vorbereitungen
der länder auf gäste von außen da weiß
ich zum beispiel aus griechenland da
waren die korona zahlen sehr gering dass
man sehr vorbereitet ist weil man weiß
wie wichtig für eine solches land die
griechenland der tourismus ist und wenn
wir das hinkriegen nach dem vierzehnten
juni europäische vereinbarte standards
auch klar was nicht ist vielleicht wenn
man alle diskotheken weiter geschlossen
halten kann
so wie wir sie in deutschland noch
geschlossen haben dann wäre das ein
guter schritt zu diesem europäischen
gemeinsinn und auch zur der
reisefreiheit die dann wieder
stattfinden kann
frau kipping das kleine montenegro wirkt
jetzt damit wirbt damit vollständig
corona frei zu sein
nichts wie hin naja das kann sie also
das problem ist ja gerade dann wenn es
wieder viel mobilität gibt kann sich ja
so ein zustand ganz schnell ändern also
orte die erstmal hotspot waren es wenn
die abgeriegelt werden
schon nach ein paar wochen sozusagen
auch immer total frei sein und orte die
0 hatten wenn da vier mal ein super
splatter hinkommt können sich das kann
sich halt ganz schnell verändern
deswegen sollte man sich da nicht ein
falscher sicherheit wiegen
ich würde das auch noch mal sagen weil
ich verstehe vollkommen dass jetzt
geworben wird von herrn messner dass
leute nach italien kommen aber ich
glaube wir kommen an einer tatsache
nicht vorbei selbst wenn alle
gesetzlichen beschränkungen und
reisewarnung fallen sollten was glaube
ich nicht passieren wird aber selbst
wenn das passiert dann wird der für
viele menschen in diesem land der urlaub
einfach anders aussehen
zum einen weil sie vorsichtiger sind
aber auch stehen ja es gibt auch soziale
gründe die im hintergrund stehen
millionen menschen haben jetzt enorme
einkommenseinbußen hinnehmen müssen weil
sie in kurzarbeit gegangen sind oder
weil sie als selbstständige kann ihre
einkommensquelle verloren hatten
das heißt also die bereitschaft jetzt
viel geld in den urlaub zu stecken wird
bei ganz vielen menschen zurückgehen und
das heißt es wird natürlich enorme
umbruch in der tourismus branche geben
also sag mal so so ein trend weg von
einer kreuzfahrt
paddelboot fahrrad fahren statt
flugreisen
das wird ihm zu nehmen und das wird die
reisebüros vor enorme herausforderungen
stellen und klappe dann ist die politik
gefragt wird wirklich einen schutzschirm
aufzuspannen und darüber reden wir
gleich interessanterweise nur weil der
aspekt gerade angesprochen wurde es
handelt sich natürlich auch um eine
wirtschaft der tourismus um eine echte
branche und es war bezeichnend dass
markus söder nach österreich befragt
sagte urlaub in bayern ist granate und
der österreicher sebastian kurz für
volle hotels in österreich war und schon
mal sehr herzlich die deutschen einlud
aber nicht die italiener da gönnt dann
offensichtlich doch der eine dem anderen
nicht die butter auf dem brot und das
klang übrigens so wir haben uns mit
deutschland darauf verständigt dass wir
ab 15
juni die grenzen zwischen österreich und
deutschland vollkommen öffnen wollen was
andere länder betrifft wie zum beispiel
italien der ist die situation natürlich
eine problematische und insofern gibt es
hier derzeit keine perspektive auf eine
beide grenzen
wir akzeptieren keine bilateralen
verabredungen die in europa bevorzugte
korridore für touristen schaffen
die österreicher genauso wie die
italiener
kann man den solchen schutz auch vor
schieben wenn es eigentlich um den
eigenen profite also hier wird natürlich
sehr viel populismus betrieben gerade
von herrn kurz wenn schon sollten die
schengengrenzen aufgemacht werden und
den menschen die möglichkeit gegeben
werden zu reisen innerhalb dieses raumes
die hotels werden in diesem sommer nicht
voll werden die werden wahrscheinlich
mit der hälfte der normalen gäste
auskommen müssen und es wird generell
schwierig ein hotel aufzumachen wenn ich
nur die hälfte oder zimmer gebucht habe
und trotzdem das
ganze personal zu bezahlen habe aber
muss daran denken dass diese hotels da
sind der kleinstrukturierte
wirtschaftskreisläufe die gehen alle
bleibt der benziner hat von einem jahr
nicht die möglichkeit haben wieder auf
die beine zu kommen
ich zum beispiel bin ja auch touristiker
mit meinem museum 67 zum thema berg auf
die beine gestellt die im grunde eine
summe von mehreren themen sind ein
museum aber in sechs häuser verteilt wir
haben null einnahmen aber wir haben die
folgen spesen über monate hinweg und
gerade eine solche soziale struktur
wurde leuten durch briten wäre eine
ideale möglichkeit neben dem leben im
hotel neben einer wanderung im gebirge
sich kundig zu machen über das
verhältnis mensch berg ich will jetzt
nicht jammern nicht nur sagen es geht am
ende dieser pandemie
am ende sind wir noch nicht aber in
weiterer sicht am ende der pandemie auch
darum dass nicht millionen von
unternehmen in europa pleitegehen
das nicht die steuern mehr oder weniger
versichern dass die staaten dann die
belastungen die jetzt da sind auch
schultern können also ich sehe im moment
im wirtschaftlichen bereich groß im
monkey und ganz große probleme jeder
arbeitslose feder pleiten viele
verzweifelte menschen die sich einen
urlaub wahrscheinlich in den nächsten
jahren nicht mehr können und wir müssen
natürlich auch in dem werk in diskussion
führen
vielleicht ist nicht unbedingt dann
gesteigerten konsum am ende die rettung
sondern eher der verzicht als wärter
freiwillige verzicht nicht unbedingt
jetzt als balkonien in deutschland aber
eben das zurückschrauben und dass sich
bescheiden um auch ressourcen zu schonen
und die ökologie dann im vordergrund zu
stellen nun wird malen wir uns aus armin
laschet am pfingstwochenende in
deutschland sicherlich groß verreist
viele werden sich wieder in das eigene
auto setzen
man wird wieder im stau stehen und dann
werden massen den teutoburger wald
völkern stellt man sich das so vor
das weiß ich nicht wir haben am ersten
mai zum ersten mal diese situation
gehabt auch an unseren grenzen
und ich habe in dieser woche mit mark
rutte die ministerpräsidenten der
niederlande eine gemeinsame video
konferenz gemacht wo wir darum gebeten
die niederländer haben gebeten bitte zu
pfingsten jetzt nicht alle ohne buchung
an die küste fahren und ich finde so
etwas muss man respektieren wenn die
niederlande sagen wir wollen da langsam
hinein kommen vielleicht im sommer
wieder tourismus möglich man aber nicht
jetzt zu pfingsten dann sollten wir das
respektieren und das gilt für unsere
urlaubsorte in deutschland ja auch die
länder an der ostsee haben für sich
regeln aufgestellt ab wann wieder
touristen auch aus anderen bundesländern
an die ostsee fahren können und der
teutoburger wald ist immer schön aber
das ist etwas was man auch den menschen
überlassen soll
entscheidend ist einfach die regel ein
halt so egal wie häufig in deutschland
aufhielt
vielleicht es entscheidend ob eben sich
dann doch leider jeder selbst der
nächste ist das war ja die diskussion
aus der wir kamen markus söder um ihn
noch mal zu zitieren zu ihrer besonderen
freude herr laschet hat vor kurzem
gesagt wer österreich genießen will kann
das auch in bayern tun geht jetzt wer
bayern genießen will kann das auch im
sauerland tun
na ja da haben wir auch nicht ganz so
hoch aber ich meine das sind das ist ein
netter wettbewerb um die standorte man
kann auch sagen
man könnte auch mal städtetouren machen
an die dome fahren wir nach aachen oder
sonstwo
aber das ist ja nicht gut ja das ist ja
nicht die kernfrage sondern die frage
ist bewegen sich die menschen oder
verbieten wir ihnen das und ich glaube
man kann ihnen freies reisen nicht
anbieten es war auch zu keiner zeit
verboten und die idee
ich habe das bei frau kipping eben durch
gehört dass sie menschen mit kleineren
einkommen vielleicht darunter leiden
würden meine befürchtung ist wenn jeder
in deutschland urlaub macht und wir uns
nicht mehr in europa urlaub machen
werden die preise an den attraktiven
orten in deutschland steigen weil
natürlich die nachfrage viel viel größer
ist und deshalb bleibe ich auch für
menschen mit kleineren einkommen für
europäische lösungen mit europäischen
standards hockey place entscheidender
als der ort